we introduced the idea of the language
of set theory so we could talk about
this stuff
right and then we can have a common
language the first kind of language we
had was terminology
which is verbal language it's full of
words right but that wasn't all
we said well it's a bit awkward and very
long-winded if you use
words all the time and what makes maths
maths at least
visually right is that we had notation
so notation takes all this verbal stuff
and it symbolizes it so you can do it
very very
briefly succinctly it's a symbolic
language
like it's literally made of symbols and
we met some of them right
like you know these guys and these guys
and uh which way is it is it this way or
the other way
anyway there you go okay so symbols now
the last kind of language
which i said almost nothing about we
kind of just used it as a tool and we
didn't explore it very much
was that we had on the very right hand
side of the table do we have we have
diagrams right
now diagrams are also a kind
of language right it's a visual language
and in fact it's one of the most
powerful kinds
of language in fact this whole book i
almost did a whole topic on this and i
just thought oh no i
ran out of time um there's a whole maths
textbook called
and you guys can look this up if you
want it's very very interesting i don't
think our library has a copy maybe i
should get us to
buy one your local library might have
one it's called proofs without
words and all it is is diagrams
no words almost no notation very very
little
and it's just a picture and it will
prove different things like pythagoras
theory
or the area of a circle or all these
weird cool wonderful results
because diagrams visual language it's
super powerful
okay our brains have evolved to be very
very visual kinds of things
so i want to push on this a little more
uh let me illustrate for you
the power of this right um this often
makes sense of a lot of the rest of it
okay
do you remember one of the symbols i
gave you was this one okay do you
remember what it's its
name was what was the term for this
symbol match up to it remember
we call it the symmetric difference
right that was one of the names it had
other names right what were the other
names
x xor which stands for exclusive or
right now i didn't at all dwell on
why it was called this i did show you a
diagram though okay
but i wonder if you can if you thought
if you went away and thought about why
that is what is the difference
mathematically what is the difference
like if i said
what's the um i'm now thinking about
difference okay
if i said what's the difference between
five and two
and the answer is three but
mathematically the way that we represent
that
is five minus two equals three
right so the operation that matches up
with this concept
is subtraction right and that extends to
if you don't know what the numbers are
if i said what's the difference between
a and b
as numbers you'd say well a minus b
that's the difference between a and b
well in exactly the same way and we
looked at examples of this right and
you've got
on that worksheet if i said what's the
difference between two sets
you'd say that right now what does this
look like
let's just do that we can draw a rough
diagram
if you call this a and this b what would
it look like how would you describe the
shading
everything except for the center bit
well i wouldn't do the outside would i
like yeah i just do i do this part yeah
that's a minus b
that's all of a and i take away all the
things that are in b which is that
little section
ah but now can you see why this
is called this because what did the
diagram look like right
exclusive or means one or the other but
not both
in other words it looks like this
it looks to me like it's a difference
but it's
symmetrical does that make sense right
so visual language
makes sense of a lot of other things in
a very obvious way okay